all righty then what about D v e5 c5 or
the Budapest c4 the Budapest defense the
Howard Stern defense is that you could
call it somebody tweet at Howard Stern
and let him know that the Budapest
offense is being played right now
tweet Adam he is a big Budapest defense
player if you didn't know there's 94
there's Knight g4 I prefer Knight g4
just making sure I get this pawn back
but I'm an experiment with tonight e4
actually
now what righty Bishop c5 forces this
otherwise bad things happen to King
actually I'm gonna actually I don't know
if this is right I think maybe I should
have thrown in a check or something
first I might not get this pawn back I
don't know this is probably still book
if some I think okay now I'm recalling
something if Bishop plays here I think
the move is f6 with some sneaky things
to follow like if pawn takes I take with
the queen of hitting the bishop I'm
hitting the pun there's possibility for
Bishop checks okay and now that's ruled
out to forget about it but what about
still pawn push here
okay well if I play Bishop c5 light says
you know what III so much for your
threat and then is in a position to play
b4 so if I really want to play my Bishop
here after e3 I think I'll need to be
playing a5
actually I think I want to play a five
right now
I totally messed this up I it's just so
wrong this is definitely wrong I should
have just played in that g4 and got that
pawn back
well what do you do
my Knights gonna get hit let's go here
okay I'm doing this because I have ideas
of actually a four and Knight c4 to b3
and I might want to do that really soon
let's do it maybe one day there's
actually rook up and over I do my night
is unprotected if if you're looking at
this position and not seeing this Knight
as maybe being vulnerable in some way
you should it's a problem Bishop back
what do I have nothing I might have to
go with the pond sac
I might have to play this as a gambit
instead of just trying to regain this
guy and I could do that with just d6 but
pawn takes Bishop takes and then maybe
there's something crazy against the king
I could get this light square bishop
should I though I'm gonna set up some
sneaky stuff maybe I have something
against the King Knight here was also a
move I could have run with
the thing I'm setting up is pawn takes
Bishop takes I have a nasty threat of
just Knight takes bishop followed by
Bishop takes pawn
so I'm regaining this material Knight
takes Knight takes her politics
well I'm foreseeing that this night is
gonna play to c3 and I would like to I
would like to be able to be in a
position where I could play c6 to watch
over both jumping points from that night
so in other words maybe I should be
taken with my knight I have this night
off the boar it's in my pocket pushed to
c6 to defend against the night playing
to either one of these two however if I
recapture with my knight I'm giving up
Center I'm giving up my center and maybe
there's a knight move here and then I
get pushed around I'm gonna go with this
I want to keep my center and I'm saying
with this capture now that well actually
by force if white really wanted to do it
I'm going on Castle here I have to I
take with the night I'm dropping this
guy so if I'm in check oh that's not
good what happened there was my opponent
for getting that move opposite if the
rook gives check I just block here and
then follow up with King e7 it's a
comfortable spot for my king everything
is glued together and this is this is
turning out to be a disaster now for
white this is this is really tough this
is up upon what what just happened with
that I'm up material these pawns are
split my rook jumps to life the rope the
bishop has to run backwards and the rook
that can't play to this this file
a complete domino effect just with
dropping a single pun Bishop development
piling up on this guy his right thinking
about getting this guy back that's not
gonna be easy
Bishop here or here or none of the above
here I want to play my Bishop to d6 in
King to e7 to move Zed actually I guess
that was a quick three just figuring
things out f6 Bishop here King here
that's as far as I'm taking it this guy
everything is defended actually once I
have bishop here and King here
everything is protected except for this
but that's not accessible I can grab
that pond but I don't want to work
myself into a pin I guess I could take
it with the rook but there's no rush
with it you can take it on my next turn
and then quickly get out of a pin with
King to e7
okay night incoming right here maybe I
should have grabbed that pot maybe okay
well let's get my night doing something
and the main thing here is I want to
watch out for this d5 square 95 I'm in a
spot to just take this night is boxed
out as long as I maintain this structure
these two negate this guy what might he
do not a whole lot what might he do well
I guess here since there's a few pieces
on this diagonal this diagonal is shut
down because of this structure so if
anything the bishop here is running
through my mind and also this nine this
is probably the most active piece right
now for white and the one I'm most
concerned about this is something I
wanted to do earlier and now I could do
it c6 taking into account this night and
bad things happened in this game on the
b3 squared I think this was just turned
out to be a bit of a blind spot for
white b3 bad things happened on b3 let's
get out of the pin I'm on the rook I
could have also taken the rook but
there's no rush this is plenty of
material still no rush and let me just
take here
maybe I shouldn't have done that okay
let's go at this I just came back the
material she catched that I shouldn't
have done that okay let's just run fast
run fast why did I give that material up
I had a rook I had a minor piece I just
want to play here kick those Knights
around if a knight goes here first pins
pin city trouble I did that rook lifts
to defend that pawn let's come back over
back back rank back rancor you take me I
take you you have to defend unbe what's
it gonna be rook block bishop pair
connected passed pawns no time exam
all right good game let's back up I
shouldn't have messed that up that
ending no doubt but oh let's see here
hmm
I know 94 is a move but um yeah I don't
know Knight g4 is also probably going
with that next time if I even play this
at all yeah I think there's uh I think
83 is fine you definitely I think you
should really just tuck that Bishop back
and another thing you could do is just
say you know what no right at this point
when I play a5 say no you know what
you're not gonna play you're not gonna
play a4 and cramp clampdown and this a
and B pawn structure you can just play B
through yourself so you can look into
that move maybe
and also just bringing that Bishop back
to see to don't allow this night for
Bishop exchange come back watch over b3
I think that's also going to be very
important because maybe I should be
doing that myself right now after you
castle okay what happened you played
your Bishop out I play with it to see
five and you castled if you're not
playing your Bishop back to c2 I could
be playing Knight here and how
uncomfortable is it for your rook to
play to a two it's completely out of
position so look into Bishop c2 right
there and also just saying you know I
grabbed that pun and make me show some
compensation for and I think I do have
some compensation for it or me maybe I
don't pawn takes Bishop takes maybe you
could push forward in the center and get
your Bishop out in this direction I
think that's a way to go as soon as I
regain that pun I think I'm standing
better now even though I'm on Castle
this right here is very valuable having
this lock down on that structure and
having a support point on b3 and well
you can't do that pawn move so I'm right
here I think really looking to pawn
takes Bishop takes and then e for with
your Bishop to come out with your knight
to come out and I think you're standing
better I mean maybe I could be getting
your LightSquared bishop in the position
is opened up but you're still holding on
to a pond and saying you know show me
show me where that compensation is